LET'S SAY THE CORRIDOR HAS BEENE
FOR THREE HOURS SOEOPLN
HAVE LEFT TH,  GREATPLE
RI.
WA REPORTS ON SOME OF
THE FORTUNATE ONESO DESPITBEINGN
MAKE IT
>> Reporter: A TRAIN SPEEDTHROUS
POF THESE CHILDREN ARE FRO
HOSPICES KHARK
IT HADIATIVE CE EN
NOW ONREA'S MOST
INTENSEL
THE F EMOTIOS TOO
FILLED WITH INCOMPREHENSIBLWOR.
MUCH LOVE AMON
SEEN IN THE TENDERNE
TOUCH OF THE THE
WHPERED WORDS OF, YOU ARE SAFE
NOW.
LOVE OF  WHO WILL DIG
SUPER HUMA JUST TO
KEEP HERHI SAFE.
>> HI VIIAOH, AT THAT SMILE.
>> VICTORIA, WHO HAS CEREBRAL 'T
SHE HAS SO MUCH PAIN
S JUST WON'T STOP.
E
BORDER W
HUMANITARIAN TREND COULD PICK
THEM
ERA CARRIED VICTORIA FOR THREE
TRYINGO FLEEAINS SPA
SHE COULT EVEN PUT HER DOW
UNTI
FAMILIOGINSIDE UKRAINE
TO GET ON THIS TRAIN ORGANIZED
BY THEGOVERNMENT A RS CLINICAL
KILLED ANY ONE OF TH
CHILDR,  WAR.
THAT RTY THE
O UNDERSTANDABLY,
PERMITTED TOM
ANYTHING UNTIL
FED AND STABILIZED.
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU?
FI?
>> WHI TS HEADING
TOWARD SAFETY, ERA HEARD THAT
HER TOWN WAS BOMBED.
TRAIN. NOWWA THO WITH SUCH FAMI.
ER -- I , WHAT
EXTRAORDINARY THING TOITO APHE
Y END UPNG?
E HOSPITAL
WITH THE CHILDREN?
>> YEAEING SPLIT UROSS TRY W
WARSAW, AND SOMEILNGAN WAS
EXTRAORDINARY TO BE ONT
TRAIN AND TO JUST TH
COURAGE ALL OF T EMOTION  CSPAC.
AND WHAT THE MEDICAL TEA GHT NO
THE NEXT
THE DOCTORS
KHARKIALONEROUF
E SPEIVING PE
TGREATLY FOR THE WELLNGTHESE C.
HAVE TAKENY RENG THEH ALL E
SCENES TRA
AND OVERCROWDED TRAIN CARSIT'SO
THEMSE T
TO SAVE THE LIV
THE STRENGTH OF  ING JUSTD ONHO
ILSH